my briefing was a total failure but you
told captain holt it went great in such
a normal way
i'm a terrible manager i've got this
super eager know-it-all in my squad who
keeps derailing me with all his ideas
and i can't get anything done
oh you got a navy
no he is not an amy i am nothing like
gary
uh first of all gary and amy are the
exact same name let me ask you this
did he already send you nine follow-up
emails about the briefing
30. no got an amy guys i think i would
know if my gary was an amy
hey gary what you're reading the new
issue of stationary monthly yeah i have
an amy
why does terry's team have four wins he
only won stakes
bowling and the mobile escape room
you're forgetting about our breakfast at
the empire state building it was
so cold up there sounds a lot better
than our indoor skydiving lunch
speaking of which are we gonna get
reimbursed for that how dare you
complain about the fantastic fly zone
that was fantastic fun for everyone so
what are you guys planning for today oh
nothing much
we're just gonna keep it casual us too
super cash
super duper cash we all know
you're both planning something insanely
complicated and annoying
your teammates are turning against you
terry i'm on your team who cares
we're gonna win team lunch a bunch
forever i'm
sergeant amy santiago and i'm your new
commanding officer
i have big plans for us but it's always
best to start with something small
and do it perfectly so
sergeant i know what we should start
with oh i'm sorry officer
jennings gary jennings officer jennings
i already have a plan okay well you just
paused so i thought you were looking for
suggestions which i have a lot of
nope not why i paused anyway
our first order of business will be
updating the filing system
so
we should use barcodes no no no no need
to jump in
i already have a system in mind okay
well you just keep stopping so i uh to
pour water
because i'm thirsty got it great now
let's
get into the details of this with oh my
god what gary
you're spilling water everywhere
yes i am because our first order of
business
is cleaning this floor what the hell
guys oh god they found us don't let them
take me why are you hiding from us this
lunch competition has gotten
out of hand no one is having fun i keep
having panic dreams about sergeant
santiago shooting down my lunch ideas
historic walking tours don't win lunch
gary no one cares about winning
lunch please just leave us alone
gary wait look oh ow why did you do that
oh my god
it was an accident this thing is not a
safety oh
oh stop help guys
gary is killing my productivity terry
how did you used to deal with having an
amy
i didn't have to do anything you've
always been great cut the crap terry i'm
drowning
fine when you got too difficult to deal
with i'd pull rank
did that work no not even once oh my god
i'm so sorry
well you could always just wait for gary
to find his jake and then eventually
over time they'll each become 10
easier to deal with gary will never find
love we would like to say
we're sorry for letting this competition
get the best of us and to make it up to
you
we figured out what to do for lunch
please whatever your new idea is i just
don't want to get shot again ugh gary it
was a paintball suck it up
isn't this supposed to be an apology yes
you're right i'm sorry
i mean i shot my husband with a real
bullet two years ago and it comes up way
less than this way
less than this so my friend wanda she
just loves the oceans
the pacific the atlantic the indian oh
ooh
what is her take on straights because i
love the bearing
we talked about bodies of water for
hours damn the force is strong with this
amy
look i wasn't gonna tell you this but
you should just do what i used to do
when i needed to escape you what did you
do
literally escape you always be on the
move never be static like a shark that
way you can't catch your attention
that's right
that is what we did wait you all did
that
okay but rosa how did you rosa where is
she
damn you guys are good sergeant
i need to tell you something great can't
wait to hear it first could you pass
that thing over there sure
yes oh what thing i don't sergeant
sergeant oh hey
sergeant sergeant
okay let's finally get these shelves up
[Music]
oh there you are i was trying to tell
you not to use that wall
it has water damage noted
we lost sight of what this was all
really about building morale so we
bought two-ply toilet paper for the
whole squad
michael shotgun shotgun also i sold the
teppanyaki grill and used the money to
turn the briefing room into
the lunch zone oh no what's the lunch
zone is it someplace we have to put on a
harness and not eat lunch
there are no harnesses there are phone
chargers and noise-canceling headphones
so you can eat your lunch and stare at
your phone and you won't have to see or
hear anyone you work with
it's perfect it's it's absolutely
perfect we're so glad you like it
just to be sure i'm not gonna get shot
oh my god gary yes
you won't get shot oh officer jennings
can i speak to you for a minute of
course
nothing i like more than one-on-one time
with my boss wow it's like staring in a
mirror what
nothing listen i want to apologize i
ignored your ideas and that was a
mistake please
tell me your suggestions for the filing
system it's actually five suggestions
and 23 sub suggestions and i
after the briefing oh copy that
all right listen up squad we had
increased criminal activity in the park
last night so we'll be doubling our
patrols there today
after the meeting i will be handing out
new
assignments
you